joining us here World Series champion
and an analyst for Fox Sports and also a
special adviser to the New York Yankees
good to see you wish we missed you too
we missed you too we're like we had to
get swish in here certainly on a day
where it could be Yankees Red Sox of
course before we get to that though what
did you think of last night's okay well
I thought it was mean I think that was
what a lot of people expected to happen
now let's talk about the Oakland A's - I
mean I feel like what a tremendous
season I heard you talking to earlier
yeah just but Bob Melvin how awesome of
a guy is he and what he's done with that
organization Billy Beane they're still
doing it I think the one big takeaway
that you could take away from that
wild-card game is the fact that in
today's age in today's game you don't
necessarily need to have the heaviest
payroll to be successful and I think
that's what the Oakland A's are showing
us along with analytics the sabermetrics
of the game you can gain that added
advantage without paying top dollar for
a fleet and it was in terms of a new
millennium baseball game the fact that
the A's were immune to pitch counts
blind built up on their pitchers because
they were just relievers and I guess the
only way that the pitch count would have
mattered is if suddenly a reliever that
doesn't usually go more than one inning
suddenly now has 25 thirty touches on
the odometer whereas there was an issue
with that with Severino with the Yankees
and then then the script kind of flipped
after the Yankees got an early start and
Trevino came in and started throwing
seeds for the A's yeah it's kind of
strange I think if you look at how the
game went down at general obviously the
Oakland A's used what's called an opener
right is where you have a bullpen guy
that comes into the game right not a
starter cracker but an opener but we
also saw the success of the Tampa Bay
Rays had with this all season long I
mean this team had more wins or the same
amount of wins the Cleveland Indians who
won the AL Central so if we look at the
success that they've had and how they
went about doing it they had a lot of
injuries to their starting rotation
right so they started using these
relievers to come in the game early
right
now it works and it sounds like it's
great on paper but you have to remember
these guys are human beings as well and
when you go out in the bar
the first inning in Yankee Stadium in
the Bronx and that place is absolutely
rocking that heart starts beating a
little faster and a little faster and
it's like I explained it to my wife last
night it's like it's like a boxer or a
football player when you use that sort
of an idea or that sort of a rotation it
all works great until you get punched in
the mouth and then everybody has a plan
until you first get hit and that's what
happened with judge he hits the two-run
bomb and then the Oakland A's are
playing from behind the entire game and
then all but then it got to because of
the success of the opener to the pen
correct it started feeling like the A's
were leading that came even though they
were down by two and that that's why I
think that the winner of the night being
Dylan Betances it was yeah it's worth it
because he was kind he kind of shut down
that was like the closing situation
that's the strength of New York Yankees
anyways if you look at the back end of
that bullpen you have so many proven
closers you got chapman you got Dave
Robertson you've got Betances you've got
Zach Britton and you've got the guys
that can bridge you to that like your
greens your Tommy K lanes so I feel like
for them the the strength of their
bullpen is you know that's where they
need to be moving for Mick Swisher here
in the Rich Eisen show tell me your
favorite story about the heart beating
like that and a playoff game awesome
I remember so we played moves at 2006 we
actually played the old Metrodome we
played the twins and I'll never forget
that was when I had my long greasy hair
back in the day when I thought I was so
cool right and the white towels were
waving yeah you remember that it was
crazy but I'll never forget it wasn't
necessarily my heart beating but I
remember the stadium got so loud that
literally my hair was shaking and I
never hit that it was one of the loudest
places I've ever been it was that and
obviously game 6 2009 last out of the
World Series was one of the loudest
sounds I've ever heard in my life and
one of the most amazing sounds I've ever
heard so I think in general we've got to
remember that as good as everything
looks on paper you've got to go out you
still got to do it we're still human
beings it's hard to keep your you know
your heart rate in check I mean
obviously I wasn't that guy I mean my
heart rate jumped up I was I was gonna
go up with it but these guys nowadays
man they're so cool they're so calmed
it's like Aaron Judge it was just like
yeah I was supposed to do that you know
I'm supposed to hit that home run in the
first inning and so I think just in
general the
fleet nowadays is so much better we were
moving forward and I think it's just
gonna continue that true well it helps
that he does hit the home run I can only
imagine I mean the pressure that will be
building from here on out on guys like
in this series course bets and JD
Martinez and then obviously the Yankees
lineup we can we can tell the the Astros
and obviously the Indians or some really
talented teams still left in here well
who do you think is the best team still
that's the thing I feel like it's hard
in my opinion right now to say that the
Houston Astros in my opinion don't have
everything it takes to win I I don't
feel like they have any weaknesses at
all I feel like their starting rotation
is tremendous I feel like they finally
figured out the backend of their bullpen
they know exactly what they're doing
they're healthy again Alex Bregman has
has emerged themselves an MVP candidate
so to be able to have guys like that
step up on top of the guys that you
already have like Altuve Springer Correa
I think for where they are right now
they they look pretty good now that's on
paper you got to go out there you got to
actually play the game and the thing
about it is also in the playoffs I've
always said that it's the team that gets
hot and all you have to do is win 11
games and your World Series Channel so I
think in general the Yanks looked really
really good last night it was nice to
see that momentum it was nice to see
them playing that way but I'm really
excited about this Red Sox Yankee lineup
I like you're saying that TBS is like oh
this is a great man of Clue greatest
thing never happened but I just I think
it's a smart analysis that you just made
there about the Astros not having any
holes and that being what you say about
a team because baseball playoffs for
whatever reason the baseball gods with
the playoffs if you have a hole it will
find she'll find you okay like last
night uh and you are the third baseman
in the rookie third baseman he has
trouble throwing a first sometimes when
he feels like he's rushed and doesn't
have two machetes has trouble blocking
baseball's that's somebody was better
last was better less it was nice to see
that that extra effort it looked like it
was a priority and that's what you have
to have especially in the postseason
because like the old saying goes defense
wins championships and at the end of the
day you have to stop the other team from
scoring now obviously you've got the
defending World Series champs and
Astros where we all in the media I'm
warning everybody as if you don't
already know Yankees Red Sox is all
everyone's gonna be talking about yeah
ESPN is filled with Yankees and Red Sox
fans to be a custom right there in right
there on the mason-dixon line of the
Yankee sandeman and Red Sox fandom right
there in Bristol Connecticut so National
League
Nick Swisher who do you think is the
best team and then I yeah that's crazy
it's almost like we're not even talking
about anybody in the National you know
especially with all the excitement that
we just had from the two back-to-back
games to actually get our lineup set up
for the postseason it's hard for me in
my opinion not to say the Dodgers aren't
the deepest most talented team in that
league there's no doubt I feel like the
sexy ticket right now would be the
Milwaukee Brewers I mean Christian
Yelich is absolutely nasty
he's your MVP yeah I feel like he earned
that man he literally stepped his game
up and won that division for his team
hey by the way you getting that
wild-card game I've played in those
wildcard games that was reserved racking
games and this dude just goes out
nonchalantly casually three four four no
big deal he's all based like 9 out of 10
times I feel like he is one of those
guys that he's that New Age athlete he's
that long lean not necessarily like the
most muscular athlete but just that long
lead and be able to create that leverage
on the baseball and now he's coming into
his power stroke I kind of want to pound
a table for the Rockies for some reason
that they have I mean that Trevor story
kid yeah I'm a huge black it's been a
great story
Arenado their pitching staff nobody
really talks about because it's Colorado
Horace and Charlie Blackmon is one of my
favorite players that I've got you know
how dirty is that beard you know heels
and trim that thing in a minute bro so
he probably got like a cheese sandwich
in there like he's hungry in the 7th but
he like pulls it out I don't know why I
want to pound a table for the Rockies
but I do hear well but you got to love
that I mean if they have just a good a
chance as anybody else to do this thing
and I think that's the greatest part
about the playoffs is all you got to do
is you got to get in and what you get in
your athletic ability and your team is
gonna do what they need to do so I think
in general I I also like the Cleveland
Indians man
josh donaldson come on if arranged you
know Dontrelle Willis always says if
he's a shell of the of the player that
he can be that could be one of the
greatest infields ever put together with
Donaldson at third
you got Lindor short Jose Ramirez an MVP
candidate last two years second and then
you can either put you know the parrot
you put Encarnacion or you can put
Yonder Alonso over there so I feel like
if there is a team that can't compete
with the Houston Astros I do think it is
the Cleveland Indians because their
starting staff is the only staff of
baseball that can match up with the
Astros loaded it's loaded we were
talking about it Brockman right we were
talking about the older game that you
October is gonna be lit it's amazing
yeah we've been waiting for this
seemingly for six months and it's here
so there's that you've mentioned a
handful of times Nick Swisher about the
pitter-patter of your heart yeah how
difficult is it to to calm down in a
batter's box Oh
knowing that knowing that the guy on the
mound is maybe just as amped but you
have to think your way through an at-bat
here and channel the adrenaline oh I
don't know if you could put me in those
shoes here I mean I'm I'm retired I'm
still trying to figure it out I think
I'm trying to figure out how to how to
calm the heart down right I think that's
one of the things that it's not always
your athletic ability it's your ability
to be in that moment it's your ability
to understand what's at stake and and I
think that obviously the more that you
have the opportunity to do that the more
you can learn from that so I think that
was the one thing going into that Yankee
A's game last night is the Yankees have
been there before and I felt like my dad
said something to me a couple weeks ago
and he said like every time the Yankees
feel like their backs are pressed up
against the wall they come out fighting
and they always seem to play well and
they also have guys that have been there
and done that listen man this team
almost went to the World Series last
year right I mean let's let's not get
that twisted at all so now a sudden you
bring in a team of the Oakland A's who
had an unbelievably remarkable season
and got contributions from players that
you know really stepped their games up
Stephen Piscotty heard you talked about
earlier man what an amazing story well
after what happened with him horse I
mean been at bat he's probably just off
hey is a vacation for him you know I
feel like he has that something to play
for
who is the best player you were ever
been
was able to just odor cheese there's no
doubt heads down break it all out dude
this cat was just cool dog just like
this all the time manually and me you
know I'm like I'm like a heartbeat you
know I'm Sam's write up and I'm died and
he was just like this and I feel like I
learned a lot from him moving forward
because him Jorge Posada Andy pettite
Mariano Rivera all those cats did it the
same and I don't even know how I wish
whatever they were taken I press you
jumped on some of that but either way to
be able to be around those guys and to
understand they were so Pro and they
were so professional and what they did
each and every day and that was the main
thing I took away from all those guys
because when you get in those situations
you have to go back on muscle memory you
have to go back because you're trying to
focus on one thing while you obviously
you have 50,000 people going crazy yeah
so to be in that spot and to be able to
be successful more times than not like a
guy like Derek Jeter his postseason
numbers were off the charts and I always
found it just unbelievably amazing that
somebody could do that because there
were so many X factors but somehow he
found a way to tunnel vision himself
nick swisher here on the rich johnson
Cheers here's pretty good okay yeah I
know so who do you think wins at all
give me your prediction beginning here
you know what I feel like in this
position right now they asked us this
last week and last week I'll say the
same thing I got this week right now I
feel like it's going to be amazing I
feel like it's gonna be a hard-fought
battle I got the Yankees beating the Red
Sox
I've got Houston beating Cleveland and
then at the end I think I've Houston in
a seven-game split beating the Yankees
and moving on to the World Series facing
the Milwaukee Brewers you got Lee like
I'll pound on my chest man you know like
you feel like you want to pound the
table for the Rockies I feel like for
what they've done Craig Counsell to be
able to bring over the players they have
like the Lorenzo Cain's the Christian
Yelich is to be able to see what that
organization has turned into hey soos
Aguilar now the sudden that teams got
bravado they've they've got a they've
got a name they know exactly what
they're trying to do each and every day
and by the way when you're watched in
Milwaukee Brewers don't you smile you're
laughing you're having fun with them
you're like wow these are like just big
kids playing the game that we all wish
we could so I think for the success that
they've had this year I would like to
see it continue they've gotten great
pitching from a
bunch of so-called average starters to
be able to see these guys step up and
also the front office for bringing over
guys like Gio Gonzalez right after the
deadline because they need those arms to
get themselves to the World Series and
just like the Yankees their strength is
in their bullpen so when it's all said
and done you think we have a repeat with
yeah I think so I mean I'm a horrible
prognosticator there's no doubt about
that I might be the worst but I think
that's the thing about it is every every
day it changes and that's the thing is
like you know over Fox all the time and
they're saying hey who do you thinks
gonna win well if it's today that I'm
gonna say this but tomorrow might come
up and I might think something matchups
it's worse where the game's dislikes and
momentum isn't it's amazing how momentum
truly feels damageable in the base it's
crucial mass huge and I think as as a
fan base I think the fans really need to
truly understand how important they are
in these playoffs settings because I
don't care what anybody says man whether
you know the visiting team one more
wildcard games or not but I'm telling
you home-field advantage it's an
advantage for a reason you wake up every
morning you go to your favorite
breakfast spot you go to your favorite
lunch spot wherever you want to go get
the ballpark at the same time your fan
base is there they want you to succeed
so to be able to have that I mean last
night I think the crowd in Yankee
Stadium and bleacher creatures all over
the place man it was an amazing
atmosphere it was like a soccer game
right they would like throw the ball
over the place that's the excitement we
need and that's the excitement that
comes out and playoff baseball and I
think that's why in my mind we have the
best sport in the world right now as
awesome as I think football is yeah
baseball is at the forefront right now
and I think that's the coolest Park is
this is where we can gain fans this is
where we can gain the non baseball fan
into coming and joining our I guess our
world I mean it just shows you the
commitment Yankee fans had last night
throwing those beers I mean one of those
like 1250 significant expenditure the
video I saw this guy in the outfield
threw a full beer on a guy wearing a
Yank F a shirt that's crazy now
is your what is your stance Chris
Brockman has said earlier your stance on
fans who show up to the game wearing a
jersey of a team that's not laying in
the game no no I don't agree with that
at all but you're talking about the
Marlins guy no just a guy last night
like last night is somebody going to the
A's Yankees game you know LeBron Jersey
oh no or a Red Sox jersey ah you know
like wearing a jersey of a team that is
nothing but Marlins guys a perfect
example right yeah you know like I
understand you want to prep your team
but I feel like there's there's places
you know there's time and a place
exactly teams jurors in like if I'm
gonna wear Red Sox jersey I'm gonna be
going to AB Red Sox game or you know he
got upset because he went to Red Sox
Braves and somebody showed up wearing a
Yankee Jersey knee I saw tons each what
are you guys doing hey I can understand
that I mean I feel like you should there
should only be one or two jerseys in a
game that could be able to be worn right
either the home team of the visiting
team nobody else it's it you know and
everything's good with you man we're so
awesome dude Amy's going to kindergarten
now some mornings in the Swisher house
start a little earlier than normal man 6
a.m. where you want to try and wake up a
five-year-old it's it's it's it's a
different experience every morning ok
today was a great morning I knew I was
coming to the Rich Eisen show fantastic
and when you take and when you take your
daughter to kindergarten who's more of a
child yes the children playlist man we
got like a whole routine in the morning
buddy guys so for me man my morning hey
I kick ass in the mornings bro because I
feel like if I hit the ground running
right and I dominated that first hour of
the day the whole rest of my day is
gonna be amazing
yes ok so familiar hey we got to get up
at 6 we got to be out of the door at
6:45 right not 646 645 we need to be out
there what do you do when a child says I
plan hey parents I'm telling you this is
crucial right you got to start earlier
right if you got to leave the door at
6:45 you gotta start getting them out
the door at 6:35 you see what I'm saying
parenting skills right I'm learning on
the fly guys I'm learning on the fly
okay
well that's part that's part of my kid
was really responds well to routines
okay right like if you get the routine
right every morning it's the same thing
she knows what to expect every morning
and what happens after 6:45 after 6:40
we get in the car right we got to get
moving right right then there's a little
bit so and then from usually about the
first couple songs we get into my
two-year-old daughter her favorite song
is low you know boots with the far right
and she's like that's that blue foot the
fur so yeah low rider broke it songs
amazing bro we loved it but we got Amy's
playlist and then we got sailor's
playlist - - kind of different but
similar playing this because I think it
all branches back to my likes in general
so you're playing DJ behind the wheel of
the car I've done that to it but it gets
so annoying from God be honest right I
need your sunny Sun of your disposition
because I am NOT playing DJ while I'm
being the show feel like I'm a
multitasker right I feel like I can do a
couple things so you know you're you
leave bro get your Spotify playlist
Spotify right you got your playlists
you're good and then you can just you
can you can make all your adjustments
down here right so I'm driving right you
new new jam
you wouldn't knew it okay look right
next song right and so they know they
say because it feel like you get with
them and you're like hey we've got all
these different songs here right which
ones are your favorite then if you have
like a mix of like 1015 jams bro you're
good to go
Nick Swisher five-tool parents you know
what we're gonna do is take a break for
a television audience for the radio
audience I say thank you for being on
this the audience I'm gonna have you
read a passage from dr. Seuss's green
eggs and ham red want to hear your
reading your nighttime before Brett bed
parents might be a different sound
there's no full rider you gotta calm
down
calm it down right swish you got to get
that playoff moment where your
pitter-patter but you gotta just combats
it man right now I feel like I got a
little lather going right now you know
feel like I got it
radio audience when we return I have in
fact heard from a certain member of the
National Football League about a certain
nickname that I have been trying to
brand said player it Patrick mahomes
chimed in that's next
well done thank you Nick Swisher hey
last Robin so Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience